con nuestra segunda invitada del día nos
enfocamos en el lado oscuro de las
llamadas energías limpias porque para
lograr una transición energética que es
urgente según los expertos es necesario
también extraer de nuestro planeta
grandes cantidades de materias a primas
críticas es decir minerales no
renovables que se usan en las
tecnologías verdes que no solo generan
nuevos impactos ambientales Y por
supuesto nuevas dependencias sino que
también generan nuevos intereses
geopolíticos que implicarán
inevitablemente en tensiones entre las
grandes potencias ante esto hay una
pregunta cuál es el rol de los países
como China y puede la Guerra de Ucrania
analizarse desde esta perspectiva pues
se lo preguntamos a Olivia Lázaro Reyes
becania en el carnet centrada en la
geopolítica del cambio climático y
también las transiciones a estas
energías que estábamos hablando Gracias
por estar con nosotros Olivia esta
mañana de jueves la pregunta si para
lograr Entonces estás a la tecnología
que llamamos limpias se necesita mucha
minería no son Realmente merecedoras de
ese nombre hay un punto de equilibrio
entre el bien que produce la tecnología
del daño que inevitablemente se le hace
a nuestro planeta para poder producir
esta energía limpia
es
real
hay mucha reeducación que hacer
alrededor de esta noción de tecnologías
limpias lo que llamamos energías limpias
es básicamente un ensamblaje de
distintos componentes minerales que
encontramos en paneles solares en
baterías en turbinas eólicas y en
sistemas electrificados
pero para llegar al uso final de
utilidad Tenemos que pasar por varios
matices de marrón con el fin de llegar
al verde y esa es la parte de la que
tenemos que ser mucho más conscientes
como sociedad porque cuestiona
esencialmente el uso de la energía y la
dirección del viaje hacia la transición
energéticas
materials sabiendo que probablemente
Tendremos que integrar nociones de
eficiencia o de sobriedad de materiales
a medida que avanzamos hacia la
transición con el fin de no saquear el
planeta con la meta de descarbonizar y
salvar al clima
Y eso es muy importante porque muchos de
los depósitos de los que hablamos y que
Irán alimentar la transición y la
demanda por tecnologías verdes están
ubicados en países climáticamente
vulnerables en América Latina África y
el Indo Pacífico pero también en el
fondo del océano lo que genera preguntas
sobre el impacto de la extracción en los
ecosistemas
lo otro es que los depósitos de materias
primas críticas que necesitamos también
están ubicados en ecosistemas que ayudan
a regular el régimen climático global
hablamos de la Cuenca del Amazonas la
Cuenca del Congo la zona forestal húmeda
de Asia y puntos clave para la
biodiversidad como Madagascar Entonces
tenemos que entender realmente Dónde
estará bien hacer minería para que sean
utilizados los componentes resultados de
dicha minería y no seguir expandiendo
indefinidamente incluso de materiales
tenemos que racionalizar ese uso y
también tenemos que asegurarnos Y esto
es un aspecto importante que aún no está
claro y es que tenemos que tener un
marco de trabajo internacional en el que
todas las partes estén de acuerdo en
dónde está bien realizar minería y dónde
no la razón por la que menciono esto es
porque aunque existe una conciencia en
el espacio de la ocde incluyendo de
parte de actores que han sido extraídos
sobre el hecho que hay lugares en el
planeta incluyendo de parte de actores
que han sido extraídos sobre el hecho
que hay lugares del planeta que son
demasiados sensibles desde el punto de
vista ecológica para hacer minería en
ellos ese no es necesariamente el caso
en China o en Rusia
y vemos comportamientos por parte de
estos dos países que son en extremo
nocivos para el tejido social en los
países donde realizan explotación
también es extremadamente peligroso en
términos del impacto que la extracción
tendrá en ecosistemas clave que son de
hecho la línea de vida de la humanidad
en el camino hacia la así que tenemos
que ser extremadamente cuidadosos e
integrar parámetros ecológicos
colectivos en la manera como realizamos
trabajos de extracción
claro y Es que además Olivia hay muchos
puntos para analizar y precisamente
quería hablar de esta transición
energética a las energías limpias que
también obedece por supuesto a intereses
geopolíticos le preguntó Cómo se dibuja
ese nuevo mapa y quiénes son los
ganadores y quiénes son los perdedores
además el Por qué no
aún no es claro Quiénes eran los
ganadores y quienes los perdedores en
este momento china está muy avanzada en
términos de extracción procesamiento
diseño de energías limpias Y capacidad
de exportación en términos de la
transición energética Europa tiene
muchas cartas fuertes Por jugar
particularmente con respecto al
desarrollo de Green Tech el proceso de
instalación así como el potencial de
exportación y las transferencias de
dichas Green Texas hacia otras regiones
del mundo incluyendo África
pero hay en este momento una gran
reorganización de las cadenas de
suministro como resultado de la
rivalidad de sistemas con china con una
competencia muy nociva que ha estado
ocurriendo generando el temor que china
puede utilizar en el futuro esas cadenas
de suministro como arma con el fin de
avanzar en su propia agenda geopolítica
y geoeconómica
y esta reorganización la estamos viendo
en Europa con el Green deal con el plan
de materias primas que son todos
paquetes de políticas para asegurar que
Europa sea resiliente en términos de
acceso y en capacidad de procesamiento
de las materias primas necesarias para
las tecnologías verdes lo estamos viendo
en Estados Unidos con la famosa ley de
reducción de la inflación que es ahora
más o menos el paquete de políticas
industriales y tecnológicas de Estados
Unidos que acelera la transición hacia
el desarrollo de tecnologías verdes y
las inversiones En la base industrial y
de grinte que en el país en este momento
sí Olivia también hay un argumento muy
importante el cual me quisiera quisiera
que profundizarramos o no la invasión de
Ucrania perturbó la estrategia de la
diversificación de Europa esto hacia las
energías limpias como la que estamos
hablando le pregunto el Por qué dice
esto
dos razones muy simples Ucrania es uno
de los países energéticamente ricos en
el continente europeo Tienes muchos
hidrocarburos muchas fuentes de uranio
pero también tiene muchas materias
primas y minerales críticos diferentes
que son necesarios para la transición
energética es por eso que la Unión
Europea había alcanzado un pacto
estratégico con Ucrania en julio de 2021
para diversificar y desarrollar cadenas
de suministro relacionadas con dichas
materias primas críticas
y al hacer esto al tratar de traer a
Ucrania hacia una mayor integración
económica y política con la Unión
Europea eso incentivaría Ucrania a
seguir el camino de la Unión Europea
hacia la transición el pacto estratégico
con Ucrania fue solo uno de dos que la
Unión Europea había sellado hasta
entonces el otro fue con
canadás hay otros ocurriendo en este
momento pero con la secuencia y la
cronología de cómo ocurrió la guerra
podemos notar una cierta lógica por
parte de Rusia
el pacto se alcanzó en julio de 2021
hubo un proceso de subasta de varios
depósitos de materias primas en el otoño
de 2021 y la invasión comenzó en febrero
de 2022 y el elemento clave que hay que
mencionar aquí es que muchos de esos
depósitos de materias primas críticas en
las que Ucrania es rico están en las
regiones que Rusia ha tratado de anexar
en el este del país
ante todo esto Olivia le pregunto o si
cree que esta guerra por los minerales
necesarios para esta transición
energética está detrás de las
motivaciones de Vladimir Putin para
invadir a Ucrania debe entonces la
guerra en Ucrania analizarse en el marco
de una estrategia más amplia de Rusia
que intenta ejercer entonces una
influencia en otras regiones Como por
ejemplo áfrica o nuestra región de
América Latina
estoy fundamentalmente convencida que en
el futuro miraremos a la Guerra de
Ucrania como la Zona cero de la guerra
por la transición
la razón para ellos que tenemos que
mirar los dos grandes actores que
mencionaste Rusia y China
Rusia ha intentado diversificar su
economía aunque no lo parezca
especialmente desde 2014 dentro de esa
estrategia de diversificación energética
vemos que hay un intento y una intención
de exportar hidrocarburos hacia el este
sabiendo que Rusia era consciente de la
intención de la Unión Europea de hacer
una transición Más allá de los
combustibles fósiles Lo que implica que
tenía que buscar otros clientes en otras
partes del mundo para poder exportar sus
combustibles fósiles
quiere desarrollar una estrategia
diplomática nuclear y exportar su
expertise en materia nuclear a otros
países y ya lo hay más del 50% de los
reactores nucleares en el mundo siendo
explotados con base en la tecnología
rusa y luego hay algo clave por
comprender
y es que Rusia publicó en 2020 su
estrategia de materias primas críticas
que claramente dice que pretende
recuperar la primacía que existía dentro
de la unión soviética cuando de procesar
y exportar dichas materias se trata
el problema es que Rusia ya no tiene la
misma base Industrial ni la misma
capacidad financiera hoy Y eso significa
que tiene que reinvertirse Y eso
significa que tiene que reinvertir en su
base Industrial en casa y necesita
complementar eso con otras cadenas de
suministro en otras partes
principalmente en el continente africano
y en la región de América Latina
continente
y eso pasa por diversas tácticas y
estrategias vemos por por ejemplo que el
grupo Wagner que es una especie de brazo
armado semi privado del kremlin con
respecto a la estrategia de defensa y
seguridad ha sido desplegado en
distintos lugares de África ricos en
materias primas críticas
hablamos de República centroafricana
burkina faso mal y zimbabwe o Camerún y
no solo la presencia de Wagner lo que me
hace sospechar de la intención rusa de
diversificar su estrategia industrial y
tecnológica
sino también el hecho que el kremlin ha
sellado pactos en materia militar con
socios africanos que incluyen
investigación en hidrología e
investigación de minerales
y luego tiene lazos comerciales con
países en América Latina basados en el
intercambio y el reforzamiento de
interés mutuos en temas de materias
primas críticas muy notablemente con
Brasil
Así que Rusia ha estado desplegando
tácticas muy diversas tratando de ganar
acceso a esas materias primas críticas
con el objetivo de convertirse en un
poder Geo económico de la transición
energética a nivel global con la lucha
de poder en el sistema de rivalidad
actual que china inició
transmisión
Olivia eso por el lado de Rusia Pero qué
podemos decir de China
creó básicamente un incremento del
cambio de poder global con la base de
varios factores incluyendo el hecho que
desde mediados de los 80s ha sido capaz
de integrar verticalmente las cadenas de
suministro particularmente en lo
referente a la extracción el
procesamiento el desarrollo tecnológico
y la exportación de tierras raras y
otras materias primas críticas que son
básicamente la columna vertebral de la
transición energética lo que significa
que hasta ahora china Ha logrado
posicionarse como el el poder global de
la transición energética y Por ende
podría en el futuro dependiendo de cómo
se desarrolle esta competencia con
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea y
otros actores posicionarse como el gran
Salvador en materia climática
en términos de cómo implementar la
transición en casa pero también
ofreciendo servicios de mitigación y
adaptación climática a otros países que
son vulnerables y que principalmente
encontramos en el Indo Pacífico y en
África
Así que hay distintas estrategias de
influencia Y en este momento vemos un
matrimonio por interés entre Rusia y
China que No necesariamente durará mucho
en el largo plazo pero que actualmente
Funciona muy bien con Rusia actuando
como un poder Rebelde y China actuando
como uno sistemático y estructurado
tratando de cambiar drásticamente la
manera como han funcionado las
relaciones de poder en la última década